you're looking at the inside of the
strategic national stockpile all around
the country in secret locations there's
an unknown number of giant warehouses
like this one filled with billions of
dollars worth of emergency medical
supplies and you might think the
stockpile could be the solution to get
these supplies to the front lines of the
corona virus pandemic where healthcare
professionals desperately need them but
it's not that simple
President Trump is facing questions
about the role of the nation's stockpile
why not just release that stockpile now
we're not an ordering clerk the
strategic national stockpile is nearly
depleted on April 8th the Department of
Health and Human Services said that
about 90% of the personal protective
equipment in the stockpile has already
been distributed to state and local
governments so what happened why wasn't
the stockpile
ready for the coronavirus we reached out
to spokespeople at the strategic
national stockpile and they declined to
make anybody available for an interview
but they did respond to our questions
via email according to a spokesperson
the stockpile was designed and resourced
to address localized events like natural
disasters such as hurricanes or
terrorist attacks rather than nationwide
pandemic events it was formed in 1999
under President Bill Clinton the series
of secret warehouses reportedly contain
about eight billion dollars worth of
vaccines medicine protective gear
ventilators and other kinds of medical
equipment which should come as a relief
amid the corona virus hospitals across
the country are desperate to find the
gowns and the gloves and the face
shields
but while the stockpile exists to
distribute items like these in a time of
crisis it doesn't appear to have the
inventory needed to satisfy the volume
of requests it's like being on eBay with
50 other states
bidding on a ventilator states running
low on supplies can make a request to
the stockpile which then has to be
approved by the Department of Health and
Human Services before anything can be
deployed so we're asking people to be
resourceful inside their states before
they come to the federal government
president Trump's senior adviser and
son-in-law Jared Kushner said that some
states are requesting supplies they may
not need at the moment one congressman
got a call from his local hospital
saying I need 250 ventilators and he
said well you don't have a kovat patient
within four counties why do you want 250
ventilators and he says well we just
want to be safe we're very nervous right
now so what you have all over the
country is a lot of people are asking
for things that they don't necessarily
need at the moment even when stockpile
supplies are approved to be deployed
there have still been some issues the
170 ventilators that came from the
national stockpile were not working like
when California governor Gavin Newsom
said that 170 ventilators shipped from
the stockpile showed up damaged and
thousands more in storage are reportedly
unfit for use so how is the stockpile
adjusting to these issues if at all to
make a significant impact on the fight
against the kovat 19 pandemic in a
statement to Business Insider the
spokesperson said because of the finite
supply of PPE in the commercial supply
chain high transmission areas are
prioritized and quantities are based on
population the Department of Health and
Human Services now is a contract with GM
to manufacture 30,000 ventilators for
the national stockpile on April 8th
federal officials announced that GM will
replenish the stockpiles depleted
inventory of ventilators in a contract
worth about 489 million the Cova 19
crisis is the biggest test that the
strategic national stockpile has faced
so far has it already failed or is it
too early to tell as part of the
coronavirus aid package 16 billion was
allocated to build up the stock pile
with critical supplies
[Music]
so would help on the way from the
private sector along with billions and
new funds from Congress the stockpiles
effectiveness in a crisis will continue
to be tested
[Music]